and now to present the award for the
best motion picture mr. Gary Cooper
right now
hello Robert Sookie
I you've grown II say we're gonna show
some scenes from the five nominated
pictures so will somebody lower a real
motion picture screen well you better
get farther back than that that's your
this is fun you you television boys
better get a little further back than
that these movies are all in widescreen
we can't get it all on your television
set unless you backup more that won't do
it backup father take the camera to
Tarzana
how about that too well the way I
figured this is about equal to a twenty
thousand four hundred and eighteen inch
television set it's about the right size
for your living room if you've got a
limited living room the size of CPG
Miller yes sir from one end of it to the
other as a hard day's ride for Wyatt
Earp
now the nominated pictures are the
bridge on the river kwai a horizon
picture Columbia Sam Spiegel producer
ain't in place taking place
Gary wall productions 20th Century Fox
jerry wool producing cyanide Laden gets
productions Warner brother William gets
producer twelve Angry Men United Artists
Henry Fonda and Reginald Rose producers
witness for the prosecution
get with small Arthur horn blow
production United Artists Arthur horn
blows junior producer
the bridge on the river kwai
the sound stages of Hollywood have been
extended in recent years to the farthest
corners of the world
no land is inviolate to the glare of our
cameras yet that is fitting and proper
that people the world over are waiting
for a decision which only you in this
community are able to render the award
but you have so generously given to the
pictures tonight makes me very very
proud and very grateful for having been
given the distinction of producing the
best picture of the year thank you very
much
ladies and gentlemen there you've seen
it the World Series of the big leagues
of the entertainment world Hollywood
movies this show will continue every day
at your neighborhood theater for the
next 52 weeks so we'll be seeing you
you'll be seeing us good night
god bless you all